I have to just take this moment in
I cannot believe this look what God can
do
wow my grandmother was here to see me
now
she was my biggest inspiration for
everything because she was a singer and
she had the passion for it but she never
had the chance and that was the thing
that pushed me forward to continue but
I'm so grateful to have my mother here
celebrating with me my boyfriend my
sisters and my brothers back home and
then I got two of them here thank you
all for being here and supporting me
also would like to thank Bill Condon our
director who's a genius
oh my gosh I've unbelievable cast
um I'd like to thank the academy
definitely have to thank God again
wow I don't know what to say but I thank
you all for helping me keep the faith
even when I didn't believe thank you and
God bless you all
[Music]